welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's webinar using
cannabis what you need to know to get
started safely presented by dr. Kent
Crowley director of research and product
development silver state training
my name is Alexis Krause and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's
laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left to
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Crowley I will
now turn the presentation over dan it's
wonderful to be here to get to present
to this group today and so let's go
through the learning objectives our
learning objectives for this
presentation include listing three
medical conditions that cannabis has
successfully helped or treated and
describe the importance formulation and
route of administration has on the onset
and duration of action of cannabis in
humans
now the under cannabinoid system is a
biological system that regulates
physiological and cognitive processes
and is perhaps the most important
physiologic system involved in
establishing and maintaining health and
homeostasis invertebrates it is involved
in fertility pregnancy prenatal and
postnatal development appetite pain
sensation mood memory neuroprotection
and inflammation endocannabinoids play a
role in neurotransmitter and immune
systems a mitochondrial function and
have antiproliferative anti-inflammatory
and antimatter static effects the main
neurotransmitter in that's associated
with the runner's high actually is an
and amide and a back when I went to
medical school it used to be considered
in endorphin the ECS or endocannabinoid
system is made up of a system of locks
or receptors and keys cannabinoids they
can be made within our body endo or
acquired from outside of our body which
is either synthetically created or from
plant which is called phyto cannabinoids
the cb1 receptor are mainly in the CNS
but exist throughout the body
they were first cloned in 1990 the cb2
receptor first cloned in 1993 exists
mainly in the periphery but also
throughout the body cb1 and cb2
receptors are plasma membrane g-protein
coupled receptors that function as an
override the incoming signals there are
many more receptors that exist in the
body including the GPR 55 119 trip v1
and most of those physiologic functions
are still being this
today on this slide you can see THC
which locks into the receptor cb1 and
cb2 the receptor cb2 in this slide it's
showing you the two main
endocannabinoids an and amide and two AG
these endocannabinoids are endogenous
lipid based retrograde neurotransmitters
THC mimics the effects in the body of an
and amide and CBD mimics the effects of
two AG
in this slide we're looking at a diagram
of how the phyto cannabinoids in the
plant form as they exist which are in
the acid form are converted from one
cannabinoid to another the master
cannabinoid where all the other phyto
cannabinoids are created from starts
with CB GA now there's acid forms and
there's neutral forms and we'll talk
about that shortly in the most clinical
studies of cannabis today focus on the
contents of two phyto cannabinoids THC
or Delta 9 trans tetrahydrocannabinol
and CBD or cannabidiol regardless of the
fact that there have been identified a
hundred and forty-four cannabinoids and
now over 500 physiologically active
substances in cannabis in this heat map
the lc/ms concentrations of 36 cannabis
cultivars not strains but cultivars are
presented from workout a David Mary slab
and the Department of Biology at
Technion Israel Institute of Technology
and what we're looking at is how many
other types of Kanab phyto cannabinoids
are involved in a whole plant extract up
at the top of this and it's a very
detailed slide so the best way to look
at this is to go to the actual reference
in this slide you can see the types of
cultivars that they use but the point
I'm trying to make is that there's ten
types of Delta 9 10 types of CBD 10
types of c2 12 types of CBG and all of
these Fido
cannabinoids all have a physiologic
action and work in synergy turning on
and off receptors and pathways so what's
THC Delta nine tetrahydrocannabinol is
the main psychoactive component of the
cannabis plant
now I'd mention that it comes in the
acid and neutral form when you find it
in the actual plant as its living it's
produced in the acidic form the neutral
form is converted by several different
processes and it we'll talk about that
shortly THC in the neutral form is
responsible for creating that high that
people so commonly associate cannabis or
marijuana with this compound works by
imitating the effects of an and amide
the endocannabinoid a neurotransmitter
produced naturally in the human body to
help modulate sleeping eating habits as
well as the perception of pain the
effects of THC include relaxation
altered sense of sight smell hearing
fatigue hunger and reduced aggression
CBD is the same chemical formula all the
cannabinoids are C 21 H 3002 the atoms
are arranged differently and so they
interact with receptors differently that
slight variance causes THC to have a
psychoactive effect where CBD lacks such
influence CBDs failure to produce a high
effect make it a strong candidate for
medical applications and again CBD works
by imitating the effects of two AG the
effects of CBD include reduction of site
symptoms relief of convulsions nausea
decreased anxiety and inflammation in
this slide looking at the cannabis
flower and then to the left THC and to
the right
CBD in the acidic form is how the plant
creates those phyto cannabinoids these
have physiologic activity listed in red
below now when decarboxylation occurs
and this generally occurs in the plant
with time when the plant is cut down and
being prepared for processing that
process speeds up and in the lab or in
the processing or manufacturing of
cannabis by applying heat this cardbox
decarboxylation process really speeds up
and turns out acidic form of the phyto
cannabinoid into the neutral form
so following decarboxylation you can see
that Delta 9 THC has no protective
anticonvulsant muscle relaxant activity
even directly affecting our microbiome
on the right side CBD
AAA is converted from the acid form into
the neutral form of CBD which many
people find in the marketplace and it's
one of the hottest products on the
market now in the non dispensary channel
it has neuro protective antioxidant
anticonvulsant anti neoplastic
anti-anxiety antipsychotic antibiotic
and anti acne type effects down below
you see the CV - agony
which is a beta carry awfully nor
terpene it has its own physiologic
action some cannabinoids activate
different isoforms of P pars as shown
through the use of reporter gene assays
binding studies selective agonist and
knockout studies activation of all these
isoforms but primarily p par alpha and
gamma mediate some but not all of the
analgesic neuro protective neuronal
function modulation any inflammatory
metabolic anti tumour gastrointestinal
and cardiovascular affects us some
cannabinoids often in conjunction with
activation of the more traditional
target sites of action such as the cb1
and two receptors that we talked about
before peep ours also mediate some of
the effects of inhibitors of
endocannabinoid degradation or transport
which are the enzymes associated with in
this slide we're looking at another good
general resource of information and in
this wheel we're looking at terpenes
boiling points of those terpenes aromas
the effects physiologically where
they're found some of the medical
benefits and then on the outside the
associated cultivar these colors Leafly
has presented and they've been
relatively adopted into the dispensary
channel looking at the different types
of cultivars so the red generally
denotes a sativa dominant cultivar
purple represents an indica dominant
cultivar and green relates to a hybrid
some having more dominant sativa or more
dominant indica effects so if we look
down at the bottom under mersin which is
directly dead center at the bottom we
see BD which stands for Blue Dream GC
which stands for green crack a Li which
stands for a lien OG g DP which is
granddaddy purple and n L which is
Northern Lights just to give you an idea
of the different names that are
associated with those cultivars now one
of the things that are important to
think about our drug drug interactions
phyto cannabinoids are drugs they affect
our system that way and when we look at
how those agents are metabolized we look
at phase 1 elimination which is the
first phase that our liver uses to break
things down and more than 60 percent of
prescription medications are metabolized
by this Phase one elimination system or
the cytochrome p450 system and all phyto
cannabinoids inhibit certain cytochrome
p450 enzymes those main 3 families that
we see are the cyp to see
and 3a families CBD happens to be the
strongest inhibitor of all of the phyto
cannabinoids that we know to date the
most drug drug interactions involving
cytochrome p450 i so enzymes are
theoretical from in vitro work that
means outside of the body using super
therapeutic concentrations in a ten to
four hundred fold level not generally
seen clinically
so most studies show little clinical
impact when using normal therapeutic
dosing of phyto cannabinoids now two
interactions that I want you to be aware
of is one with the anticoagulant
warfarin so January of this year there
was a review of the literature and they
looked at 85 articles which distilled
down into three eligible articles to
look at one in vitro study that
indicated THC inhibits the cytochrome
p450 mediated metabolism and then two
case studies one where a man on two
separate occasions increased as
marijuana use and experienced an
increase in his INR that is a laboratory
measurement that looks at where or how
effective that any coagulation treatment
is and there's a certain set of INR
values that you want to stay within in
order to reduce the likelihood of
bleeding or reduce the likelihood of not
having enough any coagulation and
causing a anabolic event like a stroke
the second case study was looking at CBD
used for the treatment of absolute C and
what they found is that it were required
a 30 percent reduction in the in the
dose of warfarin in order to maintain
healthy therapeutic levels in that
particular patient and again a lot of
this stuff will ultimately distill down
into the genetics of those individuals
and why they happen to be more sensitive
than others one of the things that
bothers me a lot in this study is that
their assessment and Rec
nation at the bottom was we suggest
patients receiving Morphin be warned
against cannabis use and I find this to
be a real problem in the medical
literature because it's not a
contraindication what it is is it's
something that people need to be made
aware of and because of the value that
cannabis can provide people in health it
doesn't mean that because there's a
potential interaction don't consume it
in this next study clove ISM in its
active metabolite nor Club ISM is
metabolized by the cytochrome p450
enzymes as CBD that beam that to see 19
and the 3a4 family in this study using
epidemics which is now the first
phyto cannabinoid that's been approved
by the FDA for use in treatment
resistant seizures there was a two to
six-fold elevation in the active
metabolite of Clovis M and clove ISM
levels at eight weeks so this again this
is something that needs to be paid
attention to and in this particular
study which again was supported by a
company that was trying to bring this
product into the market their assessment
was that you know side effects were
reported to be in 10 of the 13 subjects
but were alleviated with CL with the
clove ISM dose reduction so they're not
making the statement and their abstract
saying that you shouldn't use it also
note is there is some genetically
predisposed individuals in treatment of
seizure disorder that use valproic acid
and what seems to be fairly clear is
that valproic acid x' liver toxicity can
actually be increased in some
individuals with the concomitant use of
cannabis and so it's very important to
look at liver function tests in anybody
that is using valproic acid as well as
cannabis at the same time now this is
really remarkable to me the National
Academy of Sciences engineering and
medicine eighteen years ago
well actually 20 years almost now did a
report following California's approval
by the voters of using medicinal
cannabis legally in the state of
California so they did a review of the
literature in 1999 and came out with
specific guidelines based on that state
of the evidence at that point in time
eighteen years later they went back to
take a look at that literature and
published those results in January of
2017 from this information each specific
research conclusion was assigned one of
five levels of evidence either
conclusive substantial moderate limited
or no or insufficient evidence in order
to define a value the committee focused
exclusively on human literature and did
not consider basic research conducted
using animal models so the committee
reached nearly a hundred conclusions
based on the consideration of more than
10,000
peer-reviewed research articles that
have been published up to that point in
time and the committee found three
medical applications for cannabis use
supported by conclusive evidence that
means that it is rock solid in
irrefutable and they found that nausea
and vomiting associated with cancer
chemotherapy chronic pain and adults in
spasticity and multiple sclerosis had
conclusive unequivocal evidence for the
medical application of cannabis in
medicine today in where do we find our
government and where do we find cannabis
being placed still is a Schedule one
drug which means there is no medically
recognized value for this powerful
adaptogenic herb in the in the practice
of medicine I just find this this
deplorable there was a study just
recently released last month looking at
twenty states and Washington DC and the
statistics of almost eight hundred and
fourteen thousand registered cannabis
patients and they found that eighty five
point five percent of those conditions
the patients were licensed to use
medical cannabis for was being used for
either the first two categories from
that study which is conclusive or
substantial evidence of efficacy
now in this information wheel another
resources you can go to you can take a
look at symptoms and conditions and
these are general pieces of information
they're not absolute they're guides and
it's something that as you are trying to
determine what to choose for your
particular ailment or symptom it's a
it's a it's a resource that will help
you wade through some of that
information that's out you know in the
marketplace it uses both human and
animal data now this is just a partial
list for the use of cannabis and medical
conditions some of the medical uses are
also listed as potential adverse events
from cannabis use
we're coming out of Israel in this
excellent study and as well has a great
reference list it looked at the use of
oral CBD or cannabidiol and the use in
children with autism spectrum disorder
to treat related symptoms and
comorbidities so there was 53 children
median age of 11 and they looked at the
conditions of self-injury and rage
hyperactivity sleep overall improvement
in adverse events in what is amazing is
the amount of improvement in self-injury
in rage sixty seven point six percent
improved they looked at what who
worsened and there was eight point eight
percent that had a worsening of a fact
of the cannabis that they use
hyperactivity symptoms improved in sixty
eight point four percent did not change
in 23% and worsened in two point six and
sleep 71.4% improved only four point
seven worsen overall improvement was
reported as seventy four point five
percent this is a really challenging
condition and to see this kind of number
in these different comorbid conditions
is just profound adverse effects were
relatively low and mainly were in a
change of appetite here's a list of
adverse events and they're generally
related to dose use and the content of
the cannabinoids and terpenoids
intolerance and other comorbid in
genetic conditions influence the
frequency and severity
Advanced REE adverse events cannabis is
used for many of these reported adverse
events to treat the symptoms or
condition and there are studies that
contradict claims of risk like causing
cancer of the lungs exacerbation of
pre-existing cardiovascular disease
decreased sex drive and sperm counts and
males and menstrual irregularities and
females many females have found that the
vaginal use of cannabis in a suppository
has helped them massively with PMS PCOS
and endometriosis it's important to know
what you use and how you use it is the
key to avoiding almost all of the
adverse events
there are many different ways to use
medical marijuana and this is a list of
many of them inhalation combustion
vaporization edibles capsules sublingual
tinctures buccal absorption transdermal
patches topical creams and suppositories
the challenges facing either a patient
or practitioner in recommending the
route of administration is that products
in these categories can have very
different components active components
in them and that formulation depending
on its route of administration will have
very different effects so it's important
to recognize the variables that these
different formulations can have on
outcomes and not make generalizations to
categorize that outcome based on a route
of administration or a particular
product form there are general
principles we can apply to routes of
administration and ratios of the major
cannabinoids and terpenoids I'm choosing
a route or product the bioavailability
and duration of action are substantially
impacted by choice of route and
formulation as well as the physiologic
impact on things like inflammation
vaporization and combustion smoking it's
still the most views and preferred route
of cannabis administration by current
consumers in states that allow it
smoking vaping nebulizing for all
inhalation delivery systems being used
today smoking the plant or vaping the
plant or its extract can yield very
different results so when I look at
inhalation I look at onset of action and
duration of action
onset of action is generally within a
minute peak effect at least in
pharmacokinetic studies looking at blood
levels usually happens in around five
minutes and it has a very short duration
of action generally one to two hours
this method may produce psychoactive
effects now if you want to do it healthy
vaporizing which means not combusting
the organic plant material is the safest
way because we're not creating by
combustion harmful toxins that are
released in this yet to be published
data using the volcano vaporization
device which is most commonly used in
studies evaluating inhalation methods of
cannabis administration this is just a
simple example showing the profound
difference in six subjects looking at
their CP max or the blood level there
was a tained at the maximum point in
time and between those six individuals
there was a range in blood level of
thirty to a hundred and eighty nanograms
per mil that is profound and it helps to
explain why three different people
taking the same amount of cannabis
following the same process of an
analytical device like a like a volcano
where they're inhaling a specific dose
holding their breath for a specific
length of time and it's hailing you can
get such a profound difference so it
shows how much variable there is between
each individual and how that active is
handled in their body in March of 2018
this study was published looking at 20
736 patients all of us 65 years old who
received medical cannabis from January
15 to October 2017 in a specialized
medical cannabis clinic outcomes of the
study were pain intensity quality life
and adverse events at the six-month
point after six months of treatment
ninety three point seven percent of the
respondents reported improvement in
their condition and reported pain levels
were reduced from a median of eight on a
scale of zero to ten to a median of four
in the conclusion our study finds that
the therapeutic use of cannabis is safe
and effective in the elderly population
cannabis use may decrease the use of
other prescription medications including
opioids in this slide we're looking at
several examples of edible forms of
marijuana as well as capsules so when I
think about edible I think about either
food products or the route of
administration which is normally
considered ingestion so you're
swallowing something so when we swallow
something we are requiring our GI tract
to absorb it process it and all that
blood flow goes directly to our liver
that is called the first pass effect and
so when we look at the onset and
duration of action of edibles that is
where you'll hear some really profound
stories but generally the onset is
considered one to two hours and the
raishin of the effect can be six to
eight hours or even much longer going
into greater than 24 hours depending on
the dose that the person takes what the
components of that product that they
took and how their own genetics work
with them metabolizing that particular
product so edibles include eating or
drinking cannabis and the bottom line is
when you're consuming THC in the neutral
form that then goes directly to the
liver what the liver does with that THC
in the neutral form is it metabolizes
211 hydroxy THC and that particular
active metabolite is three to six times
more psychoactive so depending on how
that formulation of product that you
swallowed is built you can have a
profoundly different effect between
individuals not only based on their
genetics how their liver processes
things but also what was in their
stomach at the point in time that they
consume the product you go out you have
a dinner you have a brownie afterwards
and if that dinner happens to take four
hours to cause you know complete gastric
emptying you may not have an onset of
action from what you consumed for up to
four hours after consuming it so you
hear stories of patients or friends
taking eating a brownie not feeling
anything within an hour eating another
one not feeling anything in two hours
eating another two or three and then all
of a sudden having
an effect where they felt like they were
going to die
well this is how it happens so it's very
important if you're consuming things
orally that you know whether you have an
empty stomach a full stomach and make
certain that you give plenty of time for
the effect of what you've consumed to to
start working before you consume more to
avoid in the you know an experience like
that
in this slide Vande ria Dell at Hopkins
John Hopkins behavioral pharmacology
Research Unit looked at attempting to
characterize the pharmacokinetics of
cannabis following oral administration
with three doses 10 milligrams 25
milligrams and 50 milligrams in both
blood in or the results show both the
c-max and T Max and times associated
with those doses respectively in this
slide looking at the results of the
study on the left we're looking at the
mean THC the lemon hydroxy THC and the
11 nor nine carboxy THC in blood on the
right we're looking at oral fluid versus
blood levels most all studies of
cannabis have a NIDA bias that is
looking for adverse events or efforts to
help determine reliable methods in the
field for law enforcement to use to
identify impaired vehicle operators the
consensus currently from law enforcement
is that field sobriety tests are the
most accurate and consistent method for
identifying someone under the influence
now sublingual and buccal absorption is
a very important route of administration
and those two terms are really looking
at placement in the mouth so we're
trying to optimize absorption through
the oral mucosa using either sublingual
or under the tongue versus buccal or
between cheek and gum and this really
does have a profound effect
on how absorption occurs through this
route of administration based on how
someone consumes the product generally a
few drops to two MLS of a solution are
place sublingually or under the tongue
where it's absorbed into the body
through the oral mucosa the problem with
this route of sublingual administration
using either a tincture or an ethanol
based solution or a sublingual solution
which is probably 90% or more of the
tincture labelled products that are on
the cannabis market today the problem is
that people don't hold it long enough in
their mouth for absorption through the
oral mucosa what you're supposed to do
is hold it for between five and fifteen
minutes most people on questioning will
hold it between 30 seconds and 45
seconds before they swallow it now we
already talked about what swallowing
does as far as changing that onset of
action and duration of action generally
with sublingual or buccal absorption we
have an onset of 30 minutes to an hour
with a duration of 3 to 4 hours so it's
a shorter duration and it's it's quicker
onset than edibles
but clearly much longer than inhalation
here's an example of sublingual
solutions and sprays on the far right
bottom Sativex which is available in
over 30 countries now around the world
as a prescription that's been approved
by the FDA equivalent in those countries
is roughly a 1
one ratio of CBD to THC in a sublingual
spray these other products a couple of
which are listed as tinctures are
actually
sublingual solutions based in an
oil-based product and I just want to
bring this to the attention how
interesting this is that regulators that
are sending the state regulations for
product labeling have ignored the United
States pharmacopoeia guidelines for
labeling products so these would tip
these would be considered miss branded
products if they were put into a
pharmacy for instance this is the
example of the trochee bar for a solid
tincture this is a dosage form that is
patented standardized and it's used
through the buccal route between the
upper lip and gum it uses a gold
standard of Pharma in the pharmaceutical
industry for taking an active across
mucous membranes and the importance that
I bring this particular dosage form up
and why it's placed Buckley is that the
creation of saliva is one of the
challenges for holding something in your
mouth so it can be absorbed through the
oral mucosa by placing a serving of this
under the upper lip and gum that
produces the least amount of saliva
which allows for a much longer time of
dissolution and that means that much
less of that medication is being
swallowed in turning being turned into
an edible form of route of
administration this is an excellent
study looking at Sativex during a phase
three study what the reason that I bring
this up is that the bioavailability in
this particular study looking at oral
mucosa versus an oral route swallowing
has very very high bioavailability
levels and you don't see a 92.6% average
bioavailability in most of the other
published studies looking at the oral
route of administration can also see a
very significant difference in C and C
Max and T max between both low and high
dose
in part one of this study 49
participants were asked to self-report
pain perception before an after
administration taking a trochee lozenge
using an 11-point pain intensity numeric
rating scale 15 males 34 females with an
average age of 59 59 point nine years
participated with the diagnosis of
chronic non-cancer pain what we saw was
a average reduction of 4.9 points in
that 0 to 10 scale in pain and 31 of
those subjects were using opiates of
which 26 self reduced or discontinued
the opiate during a 1 to 12 week period
of time self reducing or Lee seen that
opiate without any symptoms of
withdrawal now this is profound in the
face of the current opioid epidemic and
still the reluctance of our government
to recognize the value and safety of
cannabis in reducing the effects the
side effects the risk of death with
opiates one of the interesting facts
that cannabis has in relation to opiates
or alcohol is that the respiratory
center is not affected by cannabis and
it is also not additive so if someone
took an opiate for pain and took a
benzodiazepine like valium or out of an
ORS annex for anxiety there's an
additive effect on the suppression of
the respiratory center
people ultimately can stop breathing and
die generally which happens with an
opiate overdose when you combine opiates
and alcohol that also increases the
likelihood of an opiate overdose
happening because of suppressing the
respiratory center in the brain cannabis
does not do that it doesn't potentiate
that effect that those other drugs do so
you can add safely in opiate and in fact
in the study the only information that
was provided to the patient was if you
don't feel like reaching for that bottle
of Norco or vicodin or oxycontin don't
wait until you feel like you need to do
it don't change the medication that
you're on when we start adding cannabis
safely and in appropriate dose just
don't reach for that opiate if you don't
need to and what we found is a 84
percent reduction in opiate use that is
profound and it's consistent across so
many other studies that have been
published in the last year again it
supported the onset of action of this
particular route of administered edge
form of five to forty minutes and that's
another very unique thing that this
particular patented delivery system does
it has an onset of action of five
minutes or less and a duration of action
similar to to an edible
there is a link that you will see that
we cannot play right now looking at a
Vietnam War veteran uncle Cerf so at
your leisure
select the link and watch the short
video
now transdermal patches and creams make
up a huge product line in dispensaries
and CBD products outside of dispensaries
across the country
they include sprays cream SAVs lotions
bath salts patches massage oils and
lubricants combination of different
ratios that have acids and neutral forms
of phyto cannabinoids with many other
active ingredients that have their own
physiologic benefits are incorporated in
these formulas topical effects differ
from other medicating methods in that
they don't provide generally the
cerebral stimulation that users describe
as being high because of this topicals
many times are appropriate for consumers
needing a clear head with localized pain
relief so what is a good starting dose
most patients naive the cannabis should
begin with CBD for one to three days and
then add THC generally in the 1 to 5
milligram dose starting near bedtime
if CBD is not achieving the desired
results that the patient is looking for
one of the things that is important to
recognize is that CBD is the antidote to
the psychoactive effects of THC so that
if you took too much THC you could
consume a CBD product that had a fast
onset of action and actually helped
rescue you and reduce that overwhelming
psychoactive effect that may make you
feel uncomfortable
always start low on your dose and go
slow if you have a history if you're a
practitioner out there and you're just
now stepping in attempting to engage
with your patients asking you questions
can I use cannabis will it help me all
my friends my family are telling me to
do it well start learning and the safest
way that to do this is to recommend CBD
get that on board and then add THC
generally I recommend in a 1 to 1 ratio
and start that in the evening always
have your patient wait you know be
patient wait more than one hour before
taking more especially if it's the first
time that you've ever consumed a product
and remember that one tincture or
sublingual solution or edible is not
necessarily going to give you the same
effect by going with a different brand
or different product be aware when you
ate your last meal if it's going to be
involved with processing that product
that you take if you swallow a capsule
if you eat a edible product that's going
to have an impact rather than if you use
a sublingual or buccal route or
inhalation CBD again is an anti dote so
don't ever forget that
and for first-timers it's always good to
have someone around especially if you
have mobility problems and you know
there's a risk of falling
laboratory testing now is a requirement
in states that have legal medical and or
adult use cannabis those tests vary from
state to state generally they look at
potency pesticide analysis residual
solvents heavy metals moisture content
microbial terpene and mycotoxin analysis
they're all done to make sure that you
know what actives are in that product
and that what you're taking is safe
correctly labeled and contamination free
this is an example of some of the
equipment and I don't mean to belabor
the point but it's there for you just
take a look at in this slide this is a
typical result test results analysis
this particular compliance testing is
looking at a cultivar la Alfea and it
lists the cannabinoids terpenes whether
there's pesticides in it or not and
again pesticide listing as well as all
of the other components of the analysis
or state defined here's an example of a
concentrate and the test results for
this
to give you an example of how much we do
not know how important it is to know
what actives are you're working with in
this patient that was in his mid 30s
having eight seizures a day for a very
long time treatment resistant seizure
disorder epilepsy they went to a San
Diego dispensary and obtained a three to
one
sublingual solution that had a 40
milligram per mil concentration no
terpenes put in MCT oil and the
particular cultivar was diamond OG once
the patient started that product he
became seizure free the first time in
his life and until he ran out of the
product
he was seizure free which lasted about
nine weeks they went back to the
dispensary to buy more of the 40
milligram three to one
sublingual solution but that particular
product was made from a lemon haze
extraction what happened was he lost
control of his seizures that he hadn't
had for the previous nine weeks that
within a day so a very smart staff
member that was involved in making that
product recognized that they had
switched the cultivar and so he went and
found the last portion of the diamond
doji made specifically for this patient
the sublingual solution and it again
allowed for this patient to be seizure
free and so I want you to look at the
components of these henna phyto
cannabinoids and over on the far right
end you see C B G a and C B C - can
Lloyd's that in the diamond OG there was
a little bit of CVG a and there was no
CVG a in the Lemon Haze the CBD in the
diamond OG there wasn't any and there
was only a tiny amount in the lemon haze
now generally when you go into
dispensary
you're looking at CBD THC in its
potential so that usually includes both
the neutral and the acidic form about
those as well as sometimes CBN and if
you only looked at those for you
cannabinoids you wouldn't realize that
the minor cannabinoids had were even
there or weren't there and if you chose
that same branded labelled product and
didn't know that it had a different
profile how would you know whether that
product worked or not this is just one
simple example showing you how much we
actually don't know and why it is so
risky to make an assumption picking one
product one product that happens to have
one batch number between and then
comparing it to another product or a
product made by the same company with a
different batch number you can have
these variables and these variables can
in some individuals influence success or
treatment failure
I'm going to go through a few quick case
studies in this 63 year old white male
with the diagnosis of ulcerative colitis
at age 55 was seen at the clinic for
incorporating cannabis into his
lifestyle medical management
he was cannabis naive on seven eight
sixteen Jade started CBD buccal e three
times a day and added after the third
day a one to fifteen CBD to THC high
bred ratio buccal dose of this
particular product was trochee three
days into treatment the patient noticed
an improvement in bloating in and his
abdominal discomfort after one month his
bowel habits had improved and on
September 26th of that year he had a
colonoscopy and biopsy which showed a
complete histologic cure with no sign of
the disease of ulcerative colitis in
this case study of anxiety chaos a 52
year old white female suffering from
post-traumatic stress disorder times 15
years with an increased frequency of
panic attacks post menopause presented
to a dispensary that I was at giving a
educational training to both staff and
patients walking in so her current
therapy that she was on was alprazolam
of benzodiazepine taken one milligram
three times a day as needed sertraline
which is an SSRI 100 milligrams qhs and
she was having cognitive behavioral
therapy and men using medication she was
directed to try cannabis by self
friends on presenting in the dispensary
to me she walked up holding her breath
eyes bugging out and kind of blurted out
I'm in a panic attack and I just
happened to have some CBD samples there
and so I asked her would you mind taking
20 milligrams of this trochee put in
under your upper lip and gum and so she
administered it buccal e she left me and
walked down to the other side of the
dispensary in about five minutes I
walked over to join her and a staff
member that was helping her and I
inquired how she felt the comment from
KS was the medicine you gave me felt
like my panic attack just melted away I
feel almost normal the staff member said
she observed KS calmed down and break
out of the panic attack that she saw in
her face in just minutes this is a
migraine headache case study of a 28
year old female that had migraines which
were worse around her menstrual cycle a
duration of three years and having
migraines on a daily basis for the last
seven months prior doctors prescribed
pain medication preventative medication
that caused bad side effects and had
minimal relief for her on May 1st of 16
she began taking a 12.5 milligram CBD
trophy buck a lozenge three times a day
and added a THC a a 10 milligram capsule
at bedtime to help with sleep by day two
AG experienced reduced migraines with a
numeric analog scale 0 to 10 starting at
a 7 to 8 out
can drop down to a four out of ten by
the end of the month she was having days
with no migraines and now takes CBD as
needed when she has a breakthrough
migraine this is a Parkinson case study
60 year-old white female diagnosed in
2008 her biggest issue was pain with an
na s of 8 out of 10 her Parkinson's
symptoms were most notable as stiffness
and tremor she was taking vicodin
previously for 30 years ativan duration
of two years and Sinemet for ten years
at a 25 milligram dose six times a day
she added cannabis on April 4th of 16
which was a combination of CBD one to
one and THC with her final dosing
looking at these 4 through 7 10
milligrams of a 1 to 1 CBD trochee three
times a day and then 1 to 2 hours before
bedtime taking 15 milligrams of THC the
latter does he achieve more pain relief
so dosing was continued on that regimen
pain level draw to an NA s of four point
four out of ten ativan she was able to
discontinue and vicodin she was able to
reduce to one half tablet per day and
what's remarkable is she was able to
reduce her sentiment from six times a
day down to two times a day and the last
case study I wanted to show you is
prostate cancer and this no one would
have ever expected this is a 68 year old
white male diagnosed two years prior
prostate cancer at a PSA of 9.0 with an
anxiety level of 8 out of 10 and he
wanted to try CBD for his anxiety he and
his previous treatment had refused
radiation tried freezing the cancer
which resulted in a treatment failure
and other problems since then he had had
no treatment and he had done no diet
changes and his family had a history of
cancer he began taking a 12.5 milligram
CBD trochee lozenge three times a day
after 7 days with minimal relief from
anxiety he upped the dose the 50
milligrams ultimately a day blood work
at day 24 showed a PSA number that had
dropped in half
he continued 50 milligrams a day and
each month PSA numbers kept falling
until the third month where he had a PSA
level of 0.9 they decided to do a biopsy
and bloodwork and cat scan and confirmed
that this individual at a complete
remission with no detectable cancer in
our particular clinic using a myriad of
different products on patients with
metastatic stage 4 cancer we have seen
over 50 remissions
I like to leave you with something to
think about cannabis is an adaptogenic
herb Anasazi state modifying cannabis
has a huge therapeutic index with no
ld50 cannabis is federally scheduled one
which means there's no medical benefit
that is recognized
federally politics and special interests
not evidence based medicine results in
his prohibition and schedule 1 drug
status the endocannabinoid system helps
maintain homeostasis or that balance
that our body strives to constantly
maintain cannabis has been used for
thousands of years in multiple countries
it was in the top 3 prescriptions
prescribed by physicians in the United
States before 1932 it's been in the u.s.
pharmacopoeia from 1950 to 1942 before
it was removed
current research conclusively proves
cannabis has medical applications thank
you for your time and attention
thank you dr. Crowley for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June of 2019
as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we will see
you next time goodbye